♪ ♪
>> Katie: THEY APPARENTLY WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
THE WORST PRESIDENT EVER IS IF
THEY HAVEN'T TRIED TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR ALREADY.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S ONLY BEEN IN
OFFICE 13 MONTHS.
THEY SURVEYED WHAT IT CALLED
PRESIDENTIAL POLITICAL EXPERTS.
AT 170 MEMBERS OF SOMETHING
CALLED THE AMERICAN POLITICAL
SCIENCE ASSOCIATION, A.K.A.
COLLEGE PROFESSORS.
THEY RANKED TROMPED AT LAST.
LET'S ASK A PRESIDENTIAL
HISTORIAN WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
ALSO A "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR WHOSE LATEST
WORK IS GAME OF THORNS, THE
INSIDE STORY OF HILLARY
CLINTON'S FAILED CAMPAIGN AND
DONALD TRUMP'S WINNING STRATEGY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TONIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
ARE 13 MONTHS IN TO THE
PRESIDENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
IS IT TOO SOON TO BE SAYING HE'S
THE WORST EVER CONSIDERING THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY?
>> YES, IT IS.
THOSE PROFESSORS WOULD FLUNK ONE
OF THEIR STUDENTS IF THEY TRIED
TO STUNT LIKE THIS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE A JUDGMENT ON THE
FIRST YEAR, AND IF YOU DID, THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPACTFUL
PRESIDENTS SINCE FDR.
JFK'S FIRST YEAR WAS A DISASTER.
HE CHANGED ON THE BAY OF PIGS
AND IT TURNED OUT POORLY.
HE DID A POOR JOB OF PREPARATION
FOR VIENNA AND KHRUSHCHEV
MISUNDERSTOOD IT.
THAT LED TO A NUCLEAR
CONFRONTATION.
REAGAN IS ONE OF AMERICA'S
GREATEST PRESIDENTS.
HIS FIRST YEAR HE WAS SHOT AND
THE ONLY THING HE GOT PAST -- HE
GOT A TAX REDUCTION.
THE BIG TAX REFORM CAME FIVE
YEARS LATER.
DONALD TRUMP, WHAT HE'S DONE IN
ONE YEAR, WIPED ISIS OFF THE MAP
IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
TURN THIS ECONOMY AROUND THAT IS
SHOOTING OFF LIKE A ROCKET.
IT'S A REMARKABLE FIRST YEAR.
>> Katie: IS ACTUALLY REMINDS
ME, REMEMBER WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS GIVEN THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE BEFORE HE EVEN
CAME INTO OFFICE?
THIS IS LIKE THAT BUT IN THE
COMPLETE REVERSE.
CAN YOU GIVE US A MORE CONTEXT
ON HOW PRESIDENTS ARE JUDGED NOT
IN THE TIME NECESSARILY THAT
THEY ARE IN OFFICE BROADLY, BUT
HISTORICALLY HOW THINGS CHANGE,
THE CONTEXT OF OUR TIMES, THE
RESULTS OF THE ACTIONS THEY TAKE
IN OFFICE AND THEIR LONG-TERM
IMPLICATION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT THEY HAVE SOME REFINED
METRICS ON JUDGING THESE
THEY WANT TO KNOW DO THEY HAVE
SOARING RHETORIC RHETORIC.
THEY WANT TO KNOW HAVE THEY
SCRIBBLED THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH,
CREATED NEW OFFICES IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH REMOVE THE
CABINET OFFICES AROUND.
THEY WANT TO KNOW HAVE THEY
PRESIDED OVER A POPULAR WAR AND
WON IT?
THEY HAVE ALL OF THESE METRICS,
BUT I WANT TO TELL YOU THIS,
THEY CHEAT!
GEORGE W. BUSH CAN SIGN OFF
EVERY ONE OF THEIR LITTLE BOXES
AND THEY RATE HIM AS A HORRIBLE
PRESIDENT.
THOSE METRICS JUST DON'T HOLD
UP.
THEY JUST DON'T WORK.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE A TOP TEN
PRESIDENT, GO TO YOUTUBE AND
LOOK TOP TEN PRESIDENTS, DOUG
WEED
I JUST PUT ONE OUT AND WORKED
TWO YEARS ON IT.
>> Katie: ONE FINAL NOTE.
THIS OBVIOUSLY COMES AT A VERY
PARTISAN TIME IN OUR COUNTRY,
PROBABLY A REFLECTION OF THE
RESULTS.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY TO THOSE THAT
ARE LOOKING AT THIS IN TERMS OF
HAVING SOME PATIENTS WITH THE
PROCESS AND JUDGING HISTORY NOT
JUST IN 13 MONTHS OF TIME, BUT
IN THE BROADER ASPECT OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> HISTORY WILL GRIND UP ALL OF
THIS BITTERNESS AND MEANNESS.
>> Katie: THANK GOODNESS!
>> TRUMP WILL STAND ON WHAT HE
HAS ACCOMPLISHED AND IF IT'S
GOOD IT WILL BE GOOD AND ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT LOVE DRUNK AND
REJOICE.
IF IT'S BAD THAT ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT LOVE TERM WILL BE SAD.
BUT HISTORY WON'T BE FOOLED.